- I love reading inspirational quotes
and Gandhi's quote really stuck with me.
"Be the change you want
to see in the world."
My friends, we all want the gold
but we don't love the grind.
What's up with that?
So many people go after
mentors just because
they're successful at something.
They need to be successful at
what you are wanting to do.
When my mental bandwidth is the highest,
that's when I go into action mode.
First thing in the morning, the first hour
is me producing my best content, period.
I'm the host of EOFire,
an award-winning podcast
where I interview today's most inspiring
and successful entrepreneurs
seven days a week.
In four years, I've interviewed
over 1600 entrepreneurs,
amassed over 40 million listens
and have turned EOFire into a
multi-million-dollar-a-year business.
I've created two journals to help guide
entrepreneurs to success:
"The Freedom Journal" and
"The Mastery Journal."
I'm John Lee Dumas and here are my
top ten rules for success.
(inspirational music)
Five years ago, almost to the day,
is when I first heard about
podcasting for the same reason.
Because I was sick and tired
of Miley Cyrus on the radio.
I even went to the sports radio,
but I'm not a Padres or Chargers fan so
I wasn't loving the
sports talk radio either.
And these commercials were so long,
so I found podcasting as a listener
and I fell in love with the medium.
I got it right away,
on-demand targeted content.
You can listen to it and you
can really connect with people.
And I started listening
to people like Pat Flynn
who has now become my good friend.
He's right here in San Diego.
Andrew Warner, David Siteman Garland,
these guys inspired me and I said,
"Man, I don't have to
follow this traditional
route that I thought I had to."
Coming from a very traditional family,
military, et cetera,
and my eyes were opened.
And it still was a couple years before
I made that leap but in September of 2012,
that was the day that I
launched Entrepreneur On Fire.
Here we are just 1000 episodes later now,
which is crazy to think.
- That is crazy.
- Seven days a week and we average
over one million unique listens per month
in over 145 countries,
so it's really become
a platform that reaches the world.
Which I love.
- So when you think of just like,
almost becoming a lawyer and
being in some of those moments,
what was it that bubbled
over where you said
"I just can't take it any more."
Where you're just like "You know what,
I have to just do something different."
Because last time we
had a lot of folks that
have quit their jobs, replaced income,
and so if you're in that E
quadrant that we talked about
on the cash flow quadrant.
So what was it that just said, you know,
"I can't take it anymore,
I'm just going to go for it."
- For me, what was the
really big boil-over point
is I was in commercial real estate
and I did enjoy a lot of the profession,
but the reality was this:
I locked down a huge deal,
and it was going to be
a big commission check
and I was not excited about it.
I was like "Man, I am not excited
about locking down what's
going to turn out to be
a five-figure check."
Because I'm like "Now I've
got to write the contract up,
I got to do this, I got to do that."
And I'm sure a lot of people
in this room can resonate
with either your current
or your past jobs,
just not being excited about
what it's going to take
to get to do what you need to do.
And I said "If I'm not even
excited about bringing in
this big commission, this
is as good as it gets.
IS this the rest of my life,
is this what the rest of my
life is going to be like,
where I'm just looking at the watch,
trying to make a beeline
home as soon as possible,
locking down big deals, not even caring.
Is that going to be my life?"
And I said "That's it,
I refuse to live a life on those terms,
I want to take control."
It had always been at the back of my mind,
I'm loving listening to these interviews
with inspiring entrepreneurs.
Pat Flynn's podcast was twice a month,
David Siteman Garland's once a week,
Andrew Warner, once a week.
And they were bringing on great guests
and telling great stories,
and I was listening to these interviews
as I was driving to work being like
"Man, I need more of these.
Because I'm driving to five
days a week, hitting the gym,
I need more."
And I couldn't find it.
And so the idea was in
the back of my mind.
I love reading inspirational quotes,
and Gandhi's quote really stuck with me.
"Be the change you want
to see in the world."
I wanted to see a
seven-day-a-week podcast.
I didn't know if anybody
else wanted to see that,
but I decided to stop just whining
and complaining about the
fact that it didn't exist
and step forward and make it exist.
My friends, we all want the gold
but we don't love the grind.
What's up with that?
I get it.
We see entrepreneurs that we admire
having these amazing
experiences around the world,
we see that Olympian with
tears streaming down their face
as the Stars and Stripes go up
and "The Star-Spangled Banner" is playing.
But my friends, that's just a snapshot
of the success of their lives.
You don't see that 10 years of failure
that that entrepreneur went through
to get to success.
You don't see those four years of sweat
that Olympian had to put
in to get that gold medal.
No, we just want that gold medal.
We don't even think about
the grind that it took
to stand on that podium.
It's time for a mindset
shift, Fire Nation.
I've interviewed over 1400
successful entrepreneurs,
and they all love the grind.
You must love the grind.
So set a goal, make it
big, make it meaningful,
and then start the grind.
Start it today.
The smartest thing that I
really should say that I did
and my biggest early success
was making that realization
that I needed a mentor.
Because again, I only
knew how to press Play
on a podcast, nothing else.
So I looked out there to the podcasters
that were currently at
where I wanted to be.
That's so critical, so many
people go after mentors
just because they're
successful at something.
They need to be successful at
what you are wanting to do.
They need to be where you want to be.
And for three months and a
heavy investment on my part,
rightfully so, I was mentored by Jamie.
And that's just what opened
up so many doors so quickly.
- Okay now, we had a great
question from Facebook
which was: If someone
is starting right now
and they can't afford
that kind of investment
to find a mentor or coach, what
do you suggest that they do?
Because at the very beginning,
it seems like you have
no doors and no connections.
You're just like, yourself alone
starting a podcast in your basement.
- Yeah.
- What do you suggest to them?
- So number one, I would say
getting that one-on-one
mentor is critical.
So if you know you can't afford X,
think about what you actually can afford.
What can you invest, what dollar amount,
and then just go.
For me, a great example, I have people
that come to me now all the time,
and say "John, can you
mentor me to be a podcaster?"
And I don't even have a price anymore.
I don't one-on-one mentor anymore,
I focus on other parts of my business,
But I'm able to say "I'm
sorry, I don't mentor
but I have a couple great options for you.
What's your price range?
Let me introduce you, hand
you off to an amazing mentor
who loves doing this, who's
great at what he does,
or what she does, and then
you'll be off to the races."
Fortune favors the
bold, so still reach out
with that mentality.
And also offer what kind of
value are you going to exchange?
Maybe you're willing to
run their Twitter account
and maybe you're willing
to create some images
or some design for them.
Think about the bartering that you can do,
trading your time, which is
valuable, saving them time.
There can be some really cool
things that you can exchange
that doesn't have to necessarily
be dollars and cents.
And then also I do want to add,
there's also some great
group coaching out there
that's a lot cheaper.
And then, somebody that
you've interviewed as well,
Lewis Howes, as well as myself,
we run membership masterminds.
He runs the School of Greatness.
I run Fire Nation Elite.
These are membership masterminds that are
around 100 people each.
And so it's a lot less expensive.
Whenever people reach out to me and say
"I'm doubting what I'm doing,"
I say "Well, congratulations,
you're a human being."
That's what it means to be a human.
- High five.
- You doubt what you do, it's
that voice inside our head.
It's innate in all of us.
We're born with the Imposter Syndrome,
so we don't walk outside
of the cave at dark
with a saber-toothed tiger.
It's like there's a voice saying
"Don't walk outside, it's dangerous."
But we don't live in
that same world anymore.
But we still have that inside
our head, and that's fine,
but we need to learn not
to let it control our lives
but to embrace that fear.
And so I still have it, every single day.
We talked about my revenue last month.
I still wake up and say
"Man, should I be doing,
should I do this webinar?"
I have these doubts and these fears.
That's just a reality and I've
just learned to embrace that.
This quote is by the
ex-President Theodore Roosevelt.
He delivered this in Paris back in 1910.
"It is not the critic who counts,
not the man who points out
how the strong man stumbles,
or where the doer of deeds
could have done better.
Credit belongs to the man
who is actually in the arena,
whose face is marred by
blood, by dirt, by sweat,
who strives valiantly, who
errs, who comes up short
again and again,
because there is no effort
without error and shortcoming,
but who does actually
strive to do the deeds,
who has great enthusiasms
and great devotions
and spends himself on a worthy cause.
Who, at the best in the
end, knows high achievement,
and at the worst, if he fails,
he fails daring greatly,
so that his place will never be with
those cold and timid souls
who know neither victory nor defeat."
I had this mentor, Jamie, and I was in
Cliff Ravenscraft's broadcast mastermind,
and they said "John, you're insane,
it's going to be so much work.
Don't do a seven-day-a-week podcast,
do a one-day-a-week podcast."
And I think this is really important too,
is that you need, as an entrepreneur,
to really take the great
feedback and the great advice
from those who have come before you,
from those who are mentoring you,
but at the same time you
need to listen to your gut,
to your intuition.
I took so many great pieces of advice
from both Cliff and Jamie and
applied it to my business,
but when it came to a
seven-day-a-week podcast,
my intuition, my gut was telling me
it had to be that way.
That's what I was meant to create.
I had the military discipline,
I knew how to create systems,
I knew how to work hard.
I had the finances to allow me to do so
for a significant amount of time
without being distracted by other things.
I knew that I could make it happen,
I knew that was going to be my USP.
that unique selling
proposition, my differentiator.
So I listened to my heart,
I listened to my gut,
and I think that's so
important for people to realize
that you're going to have
something in your gut
that's telling you to do something
and hopefully it's
something that is unique
and it is different.
And make sure you follow that.
- I think a lot of people
that are going to watch this,
that are watching, that start
podcasts or have podcasts,
or want to start them.
So what's kind of the
right way to do it for you?
- If you are willing to
step back and say "Hey,
I am going to commit to
delivering free, valuable
and consistent content,"
those three things.
"I'm going to commit to
delivering free, valuable,
and consistent content," you are going
to grow an audience in your niche.
If you can commit to getting
to that tipping point,
then that tipping point's going to happen
when you're doing the free,
valuable and consistent content.
You will get to revenue,
but it's not going to come
overnight, over one month.
It's going to take time, and that's why
I'm not against a side hustle.
I want to talk for just a minute about
action versus reaction.
Such a critical concept.
So many people start their
day in reaction mode.
"Let me grab my phone,
let me see what's on X,
let's see what's on Y,
let's see what's on Z.
Facebook, what's in my email,
what do people want from me?"
If you start in reaction
mode, you're likely
going to end in reaction mode.
No bueno.
We don't want to start
or end in reaction mode.
How about this, we're going
to start in action mode.
We're going to take actions
that are going to improve our business,
add value to what we're bringing
in value to other's lives.
When my mental bandwidth is the highest,
that's when I go into action mode,
first thing in the morning.
The first hour is me producing
my best content, period.
I'm not going to spend
my best mental bandwidth
answering somebody's
emails, someone's questions,
someone's ask, want, need.
No, it's your best mental bandwidth.
Reaction's part of the game though,
realize you do need to engage,
you do need to answer
those emails, those tweets,
those Facebook messages.
Did you Snapchat me?
I'm answering back, that
is part of the game.
Start to be intentional
about when you act,
and when you react.
And remember, use your
best mental bandwidth,
your energy, for action.
Fire Nation, as entrepreneurs, we love
getting right to the finish line
and then never crossing it.
You want to know why?
Because as long as we're
living in the pre-launch mode,
we're living in the fairy
world of "this might work,
it might work," but as
soon as you press Publish
thn it gets real, then
the market tells you
if this is going to work or not.
You either win or you lose.
And we are terrified of losing.
We want to live in that
comfortable pre-launch stage
of where everything and
anything is possible.
Fire Nation, everybody told
me EOFire would not work,
that a daily podcast was doomed to fail,
so I kept pushing back my
launch so I could live in
my fairy world of this might.
I wanted my dream to stay
alive a little longer,
until I pushed that go
button, that publish button,
EOFire was still possibly a success.
Reality hadn't set in.
So yes, your chances of losing
are a lot less pre-launch,
but your chances of winning are zero.
So take this away, Fire Nation.
You will lose if you remain
in your fairy-tele land
of pre-launch, and you will never win.
There's one way to win: press Launch.
Let the market decide.
The alarm clock would go off very early,
every single morning.
I'd wake up, I'd check
my phone immediately
for any emails that had come in,
and then it'd be shower,
shave, dress in my full suit,
and jump in a car.
And that car, to me, represented
my first kind of drudgery
task for the day.
It made me feel trapped because
I had done all the right things.
I had gone to college, I had been
an officer in the Army for eight years,
I had gone to corporate finance.
I had worked with John Hancock,
I'd done commercial real estate,
I had done all the right
things, and now here I was,
stuck on this hamster wheel going nowhere,
inspiring nobody, especially not myself,
and just feeling like I was trapped
in this world that I had created.
And it was a sinking pit in my stomach,
and I just was wondering "Why?
Why have I not found what I'm looking for
when I've done everything that I was told
I was supposed to do?
Here I am, years later,
on the same hamster wheel,
feeling like I'm even further behind
where I thought I was five years ago."
And this sinking mundane
feeling would just not go away.
It was ever-present with me,
and I just wanted freedom.
And I just wanted freedom.
I just wanted to do work
that I was inspired by,
and I just wanted to do
work that inspired others.
(inspirational music)
So there I was, stuck in traffic again.
But at least I had my
podcasts, or so I thought.
Then, before I knew it, poof.
My last podcast had ended,
and I scrolled through my iPod
and there was nothing left.
And I thought to myself,
"Man, I have to sit here
for another 45 minutes in traffic,
with nothing but the radio?"
I was devastated, but at that moment,
at that devastation moment, that is truly
when my "ah-ha" moment happened.
That's when the light bulb went off.
I said "What?
There's not a seven-day-a-week podcast?
There should be a podcast that comes out
every single day of the week,
that interviews inspiring and
successful entrepreneurs."
And that's when I had
my light bulb moment,
I said "There should be
someone that creates it,
why not me?
I know all these great entrepreneurs
who are hosts of their own shows,
I could be just like them, I can do this."
So I had all of these
thoughts swirling in my head.
"Am I going to fail, am I
going to look like a fool
in front of my friends and
family, who up to this point
had only seen me as a success."
And these were real fears.
I used to wake up sweating
in the middle of the night,
saying "What am I doing, this is insane."
And the only way that I would
be able to go back to sleep
was by convincing myself that
when I woke up in the morning,
I was going to give it all up
and go crawling back to my job
in commercial real estate.
But luckily for me, I would
wake up in the morning,
the sun would be shining,
and I'd say "You know what,
I'm going to give it one more day.
One more day, I'm going to sit down.
I'm going to learn what it
takes to upload a media file.
I'm going to learn how
to create great audio.
I'm going to learn what it
takes to be an interviewer,
a host of a show."
And every single day
I would get shot down,
I would struggle, I would
come up against another wall
that would knock me down,
but I kept getting up, I
kept taking one step forward
for every half-step
that I was taking back.
And slowly but surely,
I saw myself turning in
to a podcaster, right
before my very own eyes.
And it was a slow process, but it did come
and I was able to
continue to move forward,
until the launch of Entrepreneur
On Fire on September 22nd,
cause at that point,
there was no turning back.
Fire Nation, look what we've created.
Look at the inspiration we've spread
throughout this world.
A podcast, seven days a
week, interviewing the most
inspiring and successful
entrepreneurs in the world.
Seth Godin, Guy Kawasaki,
Tim Ferriss, Gary Vaynerchuk.
We are listened to in over 145 countries,
millions and millions of unique downloads.
Fire Nation, look at what we've created.
Look at what we've done.
And we've just started.
(inspirational music)
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
Ethan Pariseau asked me to,
so if there's a famous entrepreneur that
you want me to profile next,
leave it in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know, what did John say
that really resonated with you,
what lessons are you
going to take and apply
to your life or to your business?
Leave it in the comments
and I'm going to join in the discussion.
Thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you, I hope you
continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love, I'll see you soon.